サッブパッパッサアカラナン クサラッサウパサンパダー サチッッタパリオダパナン エタングブッダナサーサナン
ではよろしくお願いします
今日はダンマパダでした
展開させます 今日はそんなに難しい偈ではないんですからね
サハッサンピチ ワチャ アナッタパダ サンヒタ
エーカン アッタパダン セッヨ ヤン スッワ ウパサンマティ
サハッサンピチ ガータ アナッタパダ サンヒタ
エーカン ガータパダン セッヨ ヤン スッワ ウパサンマティ
ヨーチャ ガータ サタング バーセ アナッタパダ サンヒタ
エーカン ダンマパダン セッヨ ヤン スッワ ウパサンマティ
で  3つの偈があるんですけど
まあそんなにそれぞれ違う意味を持ってるわけではないと思います
1つ説明すれば全部終了します
これは言葉についてのお釈迦様のお考えですね
言葉と言っても この場合はあえて相手に発表する言葉や語る言葉
例えば日常の会話ではないんです
で 時々この発表する言葉っていうのはありますね
政府の発表とかね いろいろそういう公で正式的に発表するものもあるし
私たちも時々人の前で何か喋ったり発表したりはするんですね
で そういう言葉に対してのお釈迦様の考えなんですね
ですから 嘘を言っているかどうかっていうところではないんです
政府発表っていうのは世界中嘘に決まってますけど
まあだからその発表そのものについてなんですね
嘘ついてはいけないんですけど
この場合はそれは考えてはないんです
それで皆様方はよく聞いておられると思いますけど
イギリスのロンドンにハイドパークという公園がありますね
昔から有名なんですよ
ハイドパーク公園は で
みんな何かジャガイモの木箱とか持っていって
その上に乗ってよく喋るんです
で それで公に向かって喋るんです
相手が聞いてるかどうかって別にどうでもいいってことで
たまたま面白く喋る場合は
何人かそこの周りに集まって聞いたりもします
で そういう風にこの相手人々に喋るということも
一つの我々人間の文化の中でよくあることなんですね
それでこの最近のね マスコミというものが出てきて
マスコミの場合はやっぱりアナウンス
アナウンサーという職業があるんですね
で アナウンサーっていうのは
この まあ英語の単語から見れば
そんなに大胆なことではなくて
何かもうアナウンスすることだけで
なんですけど しかし アナウンサーという仕事は今
そんなシンプルな仕事でもないんですね
で 人々に向かって喋るんです
ですから アナウンサーっていうのはかなり腕が良くて
テレビなんかではね 本当に専門家も来ます
専門家ははいかいいえか
間違います 一言二言しか喋れないんですね
この専門家が喋るべき内容をアナウンサーが喋るんです
それっていうのはものすごくこの上手っていうことなんです
別に 例えばもう癌 癌の新しい研究とか
なんとかテレビで紹介する場合は
この長い間研究したこの一流の研究者が来ているんです
彼がもうデータ 彼か彼女がデータこういうこういうことやと向こうに出したところで
向こうがそれが見事に喋るんです
この先生が喋ったらほとんど誰にもわからないだろうと思います
で 同じ言葉で喋ってもやっぱりわからないっていうことになるんですね
だらだらと専門用語を使っているわけでもないんです
アナウンサーも専門用語使ってますけど
なんかやけにわかるんですね
その場合は ですから アナウンサーという仕事はあって
人に喋るという職業なんですね
だからそこはあの 最近だけじゃなくて
昔からもそういう公に向かってスピーチをする
もう喋るで言ったってスピーチですね
公に向かってスピーチをすると
演説をするという仕事っていうのは
人間の中でずっとあることなんです
動物もやっているとは思いますけど
何喋ってるのかやっぱりわからないんですね
よくカラスなんかは会議やってますよ
結構集まってね 喋るは喋るは喋るは
もうそのカラスの集まりも見たところで
一羽がメインに喋るんですよ
それに合わせて何人か何羽かまた喋ったりもするし
他の大勢のカラスたちが
まあただキャーキャーキャーというだけで
もう何も喋ってないんですね
だから この そうやってコミュニケーションするのは
まあ動物の中でもね カラスだけじゃなくて
まだいろいろ動物たちもそれはやってはいるんです
しかし 人間ほど何かやって
みんな団結して何かやるとかはよくわからないんですね
で そこはまあ そんなに脳は発達してもないしね
だから人間の場合は このスピーチすることっていうのは大事なことなんですね
それによって我々は社会をね
維持管理するし 何か新しいことを何かやったりするし
計画を立てて行動したりもするし
だからスピーチをするということはとても大変な
もう ことになってますね
で 選挙運動とかの場合はね
必ずスピーチをしなくちゃいけないんですね
それでその人々はいろいろ手段を使ってスピーチをする
それによって一般国民は投票して
もう政権が設立するんだから大変なことなんですよ
どんな政党に政権を任せますかということは
あのスピーチで決めます
だから結構大変ですよ
で 今はまあ昔は喋るだけでしたけど
今はもう書く文化もありますからね
だから戦況が違ってくると
マニフェストみたいなものをね
発表したり いろいろ文章を発表したりする
それもある ってスピーチなんですね
それから本当に口でも喋ったりもする
で その中でこれが大変大事なことですから
ほんまにできてますね
パブリックスピーキングというね
どのようにもう公でスピーチできるのかとかね
もう見事にスピーチできる技とかね
そういうものを教えてくれる
もうテキストまで出ていて
それでボロ儲けしているんですね
それでそれぞれの人々は研究してるんですね
どんなフレーズ使えばよろしいかとかね
どんな表現 どのようにプレゼンすればよろしいかとかね
段取りはどうしましょうかとかね
で そのようにこの相手の心を揺さぶるというかね
相手の考えをね 揺さぶって
まあ結局自分が言いたい方にねじって曲げてほしいんですね
だから パブリックスピーチをする人が
自分言うことにみんな賛成してほしいんですね
だから結局は私言うことを聞きなさいと
私に従いなさいという態度になっちゃうんですね
これはもう隠してるわけじゃないんですよ
政治家が喋る場合は 必ずその目的で喋ってるんです
私が本当のことを言ってますよと
だから私に投票しなさいと
その目的をはっきりしています
だから 政府発表の場合でも
政府が国民にこういうことだよということが言いたがってるんですね
それが国民がいろいろ調べたら違うんじゃないかなとかね
言ったりするとすごく怒るんですね
いい加減なことを言うなよとかね
それはあちらくちゃで噂話には対応する暇がないんだととかね
我々は正しく発表しているんだぞとかね
だから たとえ嘘であっても
政府が発表するものは
国民がもう何の疑いもなく信じなくてはいけないんですね
これはもう世界ではどんな政府もやっていることでね
ですから このパブリックスピーチスピーチの場合は決まってますね
喋る人が言うことをみんな聞かなくちゃいけないんですね
さらに進んでみると これはもうマインドコントロールなんですね
マインドコントロールにもなるし
洗脳されることにもなります
だからとても危険なことでもありますし
しかし避けられないんですね
人間である限り もう人の話は聞かなくちゃいかないんですね
社会生活する限りは この現象はもう避けられないんです
しかし これが大変なものの
はてなでしたっけ まあちょっとではなくて
かなり危険な武器にもなっています
ですから その現象についても
我々はやっぱり仏教は理性の教えですから
身の安全のために そういう各社会の現象をちゃんとスタディをして理解して
この取り扱い方法ですね
各自で学んだ方がいいやと
で 政府は責任持って 国民のために
国民の安全のために 幸福のため
その責任持ってないんです
そんな義理はないんだよという態度なんで
あるいは ある会社が何かの品物を発表するときは
会社の狙いは買いなさいよと
それ以上何目的もないんです
これを国民のために 国民の幸せのために
より豊かな生き方のために作った品物じゃないんです
しかし そういうことを使うんです
より豊かな人生と言って車を発表するんです
どういうことかと そんなことは考えていないんです
台数が売れればいいんですね
それで何か欠陥出ましたら
もうとにかくこれはもう騙して隠してやるぞと思っちゃうしね
それで法律もありますから
それ隠せなくなっちゃうと
またもうなんてリコールでしたっけ？リコールしたり色々
それまた無料で全部修理してあげますよとかね
偉そうなこと言ったりとかね
それでも何か点数一つ取ってやるぞとか
アフターサービスはとてもよくできてますよとか
そういうことで まあ私たちはこの見事に言葉に騙されるんですよ
だからといって人の話を聞かないようにしますと言ったら
これは成り立たないんです
人の話は聞かなくちゃいけない
新聞を読まなくちゃいけない
テレビのニュースとかではやっぱり聞かないとまずいんですよ
かなり不便なことになってしまいます
情報知っておかないと
だから その問題はどう解決するのかっていう
で 問題っていうのは パブリックスピーチをする人が全然相手のことを考えてるわけじゃないんです
自分の利益のために喋ってるんです
例えば 国民は暴動を起こしている
それで大変 国民互いに無損害
人を死んだり殺したり殺されたり
もう大変なことになっている
当然 国民にとっては悪いことなんですね
それで権力者たちが見事に喋ると
それで国民の平和のために喋っているように見えますけど
そうじゃないんです だから国が暴動を起こしちゃうと
権力者が危ないんだから
だから結局暴動を起こさない方が自分のためになります
それでギャーギャーギャーギャーいろいろ喋ったりする
で よくこのパブリックスピーチである一つの現象っていうのは
誰かを敵を作って そこをその敵を叩くんですね
昔はアメリカにとっては
まあソ連が何でも悪いことはソ連がやっていて
アメリカの政治家が喋ったら
昔はもう毎日ソ連が悪い
そればっかしで 全部ソ連のせいなんですね
それでソ連はもう崩壊するまで責めたんですね
別に それその放っといたって関係ないと思いますけど
だから自分の問題を それはソ連のせいやと言うんですね
で それにみんな乗っていて
で ソ連崩壊したところで
まあどうしようもなくなっちゃったんですね
まだ自分の問題はいっぱい抱えてるんですね
一つも解決してないんです
ただ 金持ちは金儲かることと
権力者が権力を握ることだけの目的で政治をやっていたんだから
国の問題そのままなんですね
これで困ったなと それでもイラクが悪かったんですよ
ほら もうイラクが悪いんです
これでもう もうこんなことで腹が立ってね
ある一部の人々はもう爆弾とかね
あのテロ事件を起こしちゃったでしょうね
それでやっともう他人のせいにするために理由が出来上がっちゃったんですね
今までなかったんです
今まで人を攻撃して壊してたんですけど
理由はなかったんですね
今度はこれでとかね 言って
もうアフガニスタンのせいで
これでまあいろいろ経済状況もいろいろになっちゃってね
リーマン・ショックやらあれやこれやとかね
これどうしようかと これもう心配しないでください
それはイランのせいなんです
今は イランをクタクタにしない限りは
もう世界は平和にならないんです
で  今度はジュネーブの
あの なんとかコンファレンスありますけど
それであの スリランカに人権侵害しているんだっていうふうに
この裁判にかけてやるぞという提案出そうとしているんです
で どこ どんな風に情報あるかどうかもよくわかりませんだけど
我々知っているのはこのテロリストから大金もらったんですね
あの女が 何でしたっけ
あのクリントン あのロッドハム
クリントンという女がね
自分の選挙運動に それで大金あげた人は一応アメリカでなんか逮捕もされましたし
武器密輸とかね 麻薬とかあれやこれやでね
で しかし 彼女がやっぱりこのテロリストを応援しなくちゃいけないんだということで
まあではないんだけど
なんとかまあ頑張ってるんですけど
で だから今スリランカ人も口がうるさいんだからね
もう体が小さい国として弱い
悪にはね だからもう人権侵害とか
国は完璧平和で民主主義でやってますけど
完璧っていうのは国際的に見れば我々には文句言いたいところいっぱいありますけど
あるんだけど そんなのはどんな国にでもあることで
もう野党側だけもうかなり潤って与党与党側で野党側にも何もないとかね
そんなのは文句 それはやっぱり国際的なことだからね
どこでもあることでね
まあ文句はあるんですけど
それは国民にもいろいろちょこちょこと文句あるだけで
全体的に見ればちゃんとした民主主義な民主主義国家で
きちんとした選挙があって
各地方ももう全部選挙でも選んだ人々は管理しているし
ものすごい勢いで国を発展しようと頑張ってるし
で だからみんな仲良くしているんですけど
これ白人にしてみれば大変な大変で
どこか大変で ようわからない
選挙を戦争裁判にかけなくちゃいけないんだとかね
しかし 最初は決めなくちゃいけないんだから
なんか今悩んでるみたいで
これ提案を出すか出さないかとかね
その前にスリランカはいろんなところでバカにしている
んで かなり西洋のグループをね
もうすっごくバカにして大恥かきされてるんだから
なんか今悩んでるんです
出したって意味がないんですけど
まあこちらまあスリランカ政府はもうしっかりともう投票で勝つようにしています
そう アメリカには簡単にはうまくいかないんです
だからこの誰かのせいにするっと
まあとにかくこのアジアの方にも
どこかどこかで何かあった方がいいんですよ
だから そういうふうに
この そういうことをどのようにやるのかって
やっぱりパブリックスピーチなんですね
スピーチったって口で喋るだけじゃなくて
発表するとかね まあもうフェイスブックも同じことでしょう
Twitterも同じことでしょう
公に喋る だからこの本を書いて出すっていうこともね
レポートを出すっていうことも
一つのパブリックスピーチなんですね
ただ スピーチという言葉使ってるのは
お釈迦様の時代では喋ることだけでしたから
手段は それで今 FACEBOOK もあるんだからといって状況変わったわけじゃないんです
お釈迦様ならFACEBOOKに対して何を喋るのかい？とかね
やっぱり知らんだろうとかね
そんな立派なこととかね
でもお釈迦様には勝てません
誰でも だから この根本的なところで問題をつかまって語るんです
で 人間を学んで 人間やること学んで
それについて善悪を語っているんですね
だから 人間という動物は
この公で喋ることで自分の社会を運営するんです
だから この運営の仕方が悪い方にも行ったり
良い方にも行ったり 色々それで権力者が同じ手段を自分の利益のために使う
で いろいろ品物を作る人々も
やっぱり自分の利益のためだけにその手段を使ったりする
ですから その手段についてどうするのかっていうことは
お釈迦様が自分の教えを聞く人々には
一人一人に身を守る方法として
こういうことだよということを教えているんですね
だから お釈迦様の言葉を理解していれば
もうどんな時代でも安全に生きていられる
突然 この現代社会はね
このインターネットが流行ってきたところで
突然大きな問題が起きたりしていると
いろいろトラブルが起きたりして
もう今もね インターネットはペレントコントロールというね
もう親の管理がなければ子供は見てはいけないとかね
いろいろあるんだから
やっぱりそんなにありがたい手段というわけじゃないんですね
で FACEBOOK や TWITTER ということでね
子供たちも好き勝手なことを書いたりして書いたりするんですけど
いろいろトラブルが起きたりするんですね
で 何のこともない どんな人でも
その社会から破壊してすることをしまうこともできますよ
書けばいいんだから 別に
あんたそんなこと書いてるんですけど
証拠あるのかい？と聞いたっても
相手は証拠を出す義理がないんです
インターネットだから
だから何をと言えばそれで終わりですね
そういうわけで このどんどんこの無責任に喋られるようになっちゃったんだから
このパブリックスピーチというのはちょっと問題が
酷くなっていると私は思いますね
で 良いところと言えば
昔は一部の人々だけ語る
マスコミと同じ マスコミは何でも喋る
しかし マスコミはどんな悪いことを言ったっても
一般人には喋る権利はないんです
決まってる何人かがマスコミでペラペラペラペラ喋っていて
それに反論したいんですけど
できません 発表しないんです
それはもう崩れたんですね
まあインターネットやらね FACEBOOK
やら そういう公のね 一般人がお互い仲良くする
会話をする場が現れたんだから
いくらかそれだけはいいところで
好き勝手には喋れません
みんなに自分 みんな自分の意見を言えるようになってるんですね
それはいいことなんですが
でも一般人が喋る場合は
責任を持って喋るのかと
証拠を持って喋っているのかというと
それじゃないんですね
ただ面白半分で何か打って送信する
携帯持ってなんとなく面白くなくなってきてね
じゃあ面白いと思って何かなんか打っても
そのままFACEBOOKに送信してしまうという
だから どこででもいとも簡単にも発表はできるようにはなっている
そうすると大量のパブリックスピーチがありますね
一人の人間にはすべて知ることはまたます不可能
それで自分の興味あるものだけ調べてみたりしてね
やっぱりそれも本当に
本当にそうなのかっていうこともよくわからなくなっているんですね
ですから どうなってますかね
パブリックスピーチと公で喋るという現象自体が欠かせないんだから
そうやって形変わりながら続くんです
だから公で喋れなくちゃいけないという現象は決して消してはならないんです
それが必ずしもあってほしいものなんですけど
これが大変危険でもありますね
原発と違います 原発は危険だけどあってほしいっていうことでもないんです
なくても大丈夫なんです
ちょっとエネルギーは足らないんだからといって死にはしません
その分ちょっと我慢すればいいんです
我慢する分は体にもいいんです
ちょっと寒さを我慢することは決して悪くないんだよと
体にもいいんです そういうことだから
原発には例えられません
原発と同じく危険ですけど
このパブリックスピーチという現象がもう欠かせないんです
はい それでどうするのかっていうことなんですね
この偈で  3つの偈でお釈迦様おっしゃっているのは
それでなんでお釈迦様はそんなことに関わるのかいというと
もう一つあります 宗教という世界
宗教世界っていうのはこれで始めたんですね
誰かがいきなり突然喋り出すんです
それでみんなその話を聞いて
それに乗っちゃいます
これが宗教なんです だからこのパブリックスピーチということがない
なく宗教は成り立たないんです
だからこれとものすごく精密に勉強しなくちゃいけないんですよ
仏典ではものすごい厳しいんですよ
この その場合はね お釈迦様はパブリックスピーチでしょ
公で語る 説法するっていう
そういうことだから だから喋るとはどういうことかと
もう徹底分析はしています
テレビの徹底分析と違います
本物の徹底分析なんです
これは大変なことです
今日もちょっとこちら来るの遅くなったんですけど
あの  1時から 教育放送で心の時代というなんか放送がありましてね
それを見ていたんですね
なんとかの名前は見てなかったんですけど
まあ結構まあまあ結構いいことを喋ってましたよ
自我の問題とかね まあ自我の風船と書いてね
まあそこは破った方がいいとかね
まあそれで自我があるんだから自分の思いがあってね
その思い込みで色々やってトラブルが起こる
それはその通りで まあみんなわかっていることで
そこで外に仏の世界があってね
で そこでなんとかなんとか仏の世界で
なんもうなんとかなるとね
よくわからなかったんですけど
この自我の風船に穴が開けて
これで楽になりますよとかね
なんとなくなるほど よくわかりやすいような気がするように喋ってましたけど
私はその時考えたのは
やっぱりこれは仏の世界ですよと言った途端
それでいいのかいと だって
いきなり言うでしょ この故に
この故に この故に仏の世界があるという風に言ってないんです
初めからもう決まった結論付けたこのフレーズは
ダラダラダラダラと並べて
そのフレーズに基づいてそれから語ると
これが間違いやとお釈迦様は言うんですね
まず この前提として真理を語る
前提として真理語るともう困ります
聖書もそうで 初めは言葉ありき
はい 信じなさいと それから
まあ神がもう天がありますようにと
なんだらかんだらと言って
それで現れましたと それもそれ信じて
で それから人間が住みよかったと
そこまでまあ全部信じて
それから宗教を語るんですね
それで喧嘩するなよとか
必要なことを言うんだけど
一つも成り立ってないんですね
嫉妬するなよとかね それ言ったってなんでやと言ったら
初めは言葉ありきというところから始まっているんだから
だからこのこれ宗教の世界で
もう一般的な現象で証拠を出さない
証明しない 前提としてのアイディアがたくさん並べておくんです
それから喋ったっても
なんか我々一般人に喋るところは別に反対する必要ないんですよ
喧嘩するなよとかね 悩んでる人も助けなさいよとかね
そんなこと言わなくたっても
別にもう人はやるものでしょうに
だから一般人が困るんですよ
例えば私はキリスト教はね
もうむちゃくちゃ侮辱して喋ってら皆様で困るんで
やっぱりそんなこと言われたって
もうカシス様もすごくいいことをおっしゃってるんではないかと
で 困るんですよね だって敵のことも許してあげなさいとかね
1か所で 1か所だけですけどね
言ってるし もう世界での平和の王子様だと宣伝しているし
でも平和の王子様の発表を見ると
我は世界に平和をもたらすために来たわけじゃありませんよと
我は親と子が分からさせるために来ましたよと
もう刀を持た持たせるために決まったよとはっきり言ってますけど
もうだからまあようわかりません
私なら私にはアホ以外何とも言えませんですけど
まあとにかくね それは私だけですけど
一般の方々にしてみれば
キリスト教もすごく良い人間になるようにと道徳は語っているんだから
ボロクソに神をバカにしちゃうと困るんですよ
だから我々はそれはすごく理性に基づいて勉強しなくちゃいけないんですね
だから公で喋るっていうことは
宗教の世界で公で喋る時は
まず前提として アプライとして
これはこれです これはこれです
これはこれですというところは問題なんです
初めからの神がいたんだよと
あんたどうやって知ってるのかい？と聞かなくちゃあかんですよ
なんか証拠でもあるのかいと
だから証拠を出さないで喋るんですね
これどんな宗教？同じなんです
イスラム教だろう ユダヤ教であろう
キリスト教であろう ヒンドゥー教であろう
もう神話から始まるんですね
日本のね 新しい宗教はね
車作るよりも日本は宗教を作ることにはすごい腕がいいんですよ
トヨタ会社が車作るは
他の一般人が宗教を作って売り出すは
どちらが儲かるかというと
宗教の方が儲かってるんですね
ですからこのこういう最新の現代時代に作る宗教にしたっても
フォーマットが同じなんですよ
まるっきりあの原始時代のフォーマットなんです
ある日は私は釈迦の生まれ変わりでありと
それで終わり それからそいつが言うことは全部お釈迦様の言葉なんです
調べたらダメですよ で
その人に聞いたんで 私はね
あんたお釈迦様生まれ変わってお釈迦様が喋るんだってけど
かつてのお釈迦様が喋ってることと
今のお釈迦様が喋ること正反対ですけど
それはあなた方のテキスト間違ってます
話終わり パーリ聖典に書いてある
それは間違ってます 正しいことは今喋ってるんだと
簡単でしょ いたって簡単だなと思ったんです
それでどうやってあの人はお釈迦様の生まれ変わりやとして
だって先生おっしゃってるんだから
話終わり オカーラがそう言ってるんだから
そんな程度でパブリックスピーチっていうのはね
いかに危険かと だからお釈迦様は見事にもう喋る人ではなくて
聞く人に免疫をつけてあげるんです
免疫ないんです 免疫あったならば
大川隆法という精神的に病んでる人にとっては
そう簡単に喋って逃げることはできないんです
証拠を出してくださいと
お釈迦様が涅槃に入られて
また機嫌変えて気分気持ち変わって
また生まれ変わることにしまったよとかね
何か古い文献で何か証拠が必要なんです
そういうところがわからないんだから
文献あることさえ あの人は日本語で一般人向けに書いている大乗仏教の本なんかを読んで読んでいると思いますけど
おそらく英語で書いている仏教本も読んでないかもしれません
英語はいくらか知ってますけど
その人は 仏教書いてる英語っていうのは難しいんです
結構英語能力ないと このインテリの英語を知らないと読めないんです
それどうしようもないんです
もう内容難しいんだからね
だからこの漫画で一般人に向けて書いているね
日本の先生方 学者の方々は
できるだけ物語っぽく
わかりやすく なんだかもう子供たちにでも理解できるようにと頑張って頑張って書くものはね
そんなものを読んで 手塚治虫さんの漫画読んで
これがブッダだよと思っちゃうと
もう冗談でしょ あの人は漫画家であって
芸術家であって 芸術作品作るんであって
だから全然義理がないんですよ
歴史的に史実通りに釈迦のエピソードを描いてあげないとダメやとかね
そんな責任ないんです
だから私はあの漫画で変なことがあったっても
全然一拓も痒くもないんです
それが史実やと思う人に問題があるんです
描いた人には別に彼はもう作家でしょうし
フィクション書く人であるし
だから自分の仕事をやっているだけなんです
だから気に入らんところはカットするし
よくわからないところは自分で作って付け加えたりもするし
新しいエピソードを頭で考えてもう挿入したりもするし
だからまあ私たちはね
やっぱりこの公の話を聞く能力
免疫をつけなくてはいけないんです
だから仏典でそういうところはね
ずっと気をつけているんです
鵜呑みにするなかれっていうことは大事なポイントなんで
仏教では いろんな背景の人々に喋る場合
お釈迦様が 鵜呑みにするなかれって
たとえ一行を明確に十項目に分けて語ってるんですよ
伝承だからって言ったって
もう放っておくでそんなのはと
これは伝承でありって言った途端
みんな「ああそうですか
よくわかりました」とか
まあ信じ込むんですね
たとえ伝承であったって
あれ嘘だったらどうする？「聖典にあるから」と
放っておくで そんなのはと
聖典や聖典だと拝んでる本があるかもしれませんだけど
だけど内容は嘘だったらどうしますかね
だってワルミキという人が書いた作品がありまして
インド人がそれ聖典やと思ってるんだから
あれ文学作品なんですけど
マハバーラタもそうなんですけど
だから人を頭がイカれて勝手に作家が書いた文学作品をね
聖典にしちゃったんだからと言って
かわいそうですね あの本書いた作家さんも
だからある面で言えば
どれほど腕のいい作家ですかね
ものすごい腕がいいんです
だからこのアホな連中がもうびっくりしちゃって
文章に この完成した文章だから 「
あ それは聖典だ」と 神がなければ
でなければ こんなのは書けるわけじゃないんです
ワルミキじゃなくて ワルミキに神が乗り移って喋らせましたよとかね
いろいろ言うんですね
せっかく才能ある天才的な能力あって持って生まれたワルミキさんはかわいそうで侮辱されちゃった
私から見れば ワルミキさんっていうのはそうと
どんな脳細胞持ってるのかいとびっくりするほど能力なんです
よくもここまでデータ集めて
もうこんな作品書く これ書けないぐらい大変なんです
で これまたすべて偈でしょう
なおさら難しいんです
偈だけでこの分厚い 分厚い本を書くんだから
まあだから聖典にあるんだからといってブッダを逆さには放っておけ
そんなのはと 私は直々神から聞いたんだよって言ったっても
そんなの放っておけ 気にするなよと
だから放っておいてどうしますか
内容を見なさいよと 内容を見て
自分の能力で判断しなさいと
そんなに難しいことじゃないんです
だからお釈迦様が自分が語る場合は鵜呑みにするなよと
自分で判断して 自分がこれが合っているとわかっているならば
自分で認めるのはよいし
否定するのもよしと それが正しい語り方なんです
認めるならばそれはそれでよかったと
否定するもそれはそれでよかったと
だから微塵もコントロールないでしょ
だから絶対無理なのは
このマインドコントロールする目的を捨てて公で語ることなんです
そういうのは本物の言葉になるんです
もし誰かが最初からもマインドコントロールする手段を捨てちゃうと
相手にも注意入れるんです
気をつけろよと あんたは私の言葉によって洗脳されるかもしれませんよと
よく気をつけて聞きなさいよと言いうと
本物の言葉であるといくらか信頼できますが
内容を見なさいと それでも
はい そういうふうに仏教ではこの公に喋るというね
それはTwitterにも関係あります Facebook
にも関係あります ミ mixi
でしたっけ？それにも関係あります
全て公で語るものなんです
他の様々なブロックいろいろありますけど
どちらでも関係あります
新聞でもテレビでも はい
まあそういう世界で この
ただその中でちょっとした意見ですね
このダンマパダにあるのはね
そう 今私が喋ったような
もう複雑で幅広くこの芸で語っているわけじゃないんです
ただ一つのアイデアなんですね
サハッサンピチェーワーチャ
誰かがサハッサンっていうのはサウセンで千ですね
いわゆるもう千の言葉を喋るということは
ものすごくうまく 饒舌で
もう達者で 言葉達者で喋るということなんです
ものすごく饒舌で すっごくよく語る
魅了されるように語る
感動するように語る 人々は釘付けになるようにと語る
これだけでも大変な能力なんですよ
千の言葉を語るまで相手が聞いていられませんだからね
しかし その長い長いこの言葉はアナッタパダサンヒタ
とても不幸になる意味なんですね
入っているのは だからアッタアナッタというパーリ語二つありまして
アッタっていうのは意味ということですけど
有意義 アナッタっていうのは有意義の反対ですね
だから無意味ではないんです
本当は あの 有意義と無意味と理解したら困ります
何か単語はあるはずなんですね
アッタパダっていうのは役に立つ有意義な言葉
そちらの反対になると役に立たない同時に危険なんです
ダメになっちゃうんです
だからアナッタパダっていうのは無意味な無益な言葉ではなくて
もうものすごく意味が重いんです
聞いてる間は楽しいんだけど
ダメになっちゃうんですね
例えば子供たちがものすごく満載は聞きたくて聞きたくて
よくよくむちゃくちゃ満載聞くともうかなり聞けますよ
毎日でも そうなってくると頭がおかしくなっちゃうんですね
何でもかんでもへんてこりんな目で世の中を見てしまうんですね
まともな生き方はできなくなっちゃうんですね
学校の授業は聞いていられません
もうすぐもう聞けなくなっちゃいますね
集中力はなくなっちゃうんです
満載ばっかし聞いていたんだから
だから ただ無益な無意味だけではなくて
人格が破壊していくんですね
言葉によって それでたとえ言葉巧みで饒舌で魅了される
惹かれる 感動する言葉をずっと喋ったって
それは無益な有意義な言葉ではないならば
それより栄冠あった馬断正よ
一言葉でも有意義な言葉が優れているんだと
長く喋る必要はないんです
一言葉でも有意義であるならば
有意義っていうのは 人を人格を向上させる
より良い人間にするというね
お釈迦様のこの世界は何かこの neurologist の医者がね
なんか本を書いてますよ
Buddha's brain というね
これは脳科学的にも正しいんだと
脳のいろいろ働きを説明して
日本訳もありますけど
日本訳はどんな程度のものかはよくわかりませんだけど
私は英語で読んでみたんですけど
微妙な説明で で 気に入ったのは私と同じ辛口ばっかし言ってるんです
英語で もうストレートで言わないんです
いろいろ辛口で いろんな面白おかしくてねじ曲げて言ってますけど
やっぱり脳科学的に見れば仏教しかないんだと
ブッダの方法で見事に脳が成長して発達するんだと
それはどのように発達するべきかというこの方向性まで説明して
仏教の戒定慧とかね 八正道とかね
そういうものを参考にしながら
より良い人間になる道を語ってるんです
自我の問題とかね で 本は主に仏教の本じゃなくて
脳の働きを説明する本なんですね
ですから この成長するべき
進化するべきっていうことは
脳科学的にも同じことだそうです
仏教は初めからもそのまま放っておいてはいけませんと
だから 生まれたばかりの生命っていうのは
ただの生命以外何でもないんですね
だから生命は基本的に身を守るためにしかできてないんですね
だからいつでも悪いことに反応する
それで興奮しちゃって
怒って身を守るために
身を守ることを先 それから餌を取ったりするという
だから恐怖感やら怒りやら
もう基本的な作りで で
渇愛とかね 基本的な作りで
あまり恐怖感ない場合は脳が自分で作るんです
でなきゃ不安なんです
だから誰か敵を攻撃して自分の身を守っていると
生きてる 生きてるんだという生きがいが感じるんですね
何も危険がないと自分で作るんです
妄想で 作って そこで脳が働いて
またあるやこれやとかね
体も動かしちゃって これでいつでも悪循環出来ちゃって
それはお釈迦様が心の説明としてしているんだと
同じこと脳の働きからも説明できますよと
で そこはその機能を低下させて
より幸福な生き方 慈しみに溢れた生き方
違うな生き方っていうのを作るためには
脳の最新のセクションですね
コルテックスとかね 先頭のなんとか何とかとかね
そういうところを発達させなくちゃいけないんだと
では 進化の中で 人間のこの脳の一番上にある被っているところは一番新しいセクションですね
だからそこを優先させなくちゃいけないんだと
だけど問題はそちらにもあります
この理屈とかあれやこれやとか入ってるの
そちらなんですからね
だからそこはまた整理整頓してっていうシステムで
そういうことで とにかく成長するべきっていうことは
仏教の基本的な立場なんで
成長する必要ないっていうことはちょっとありえない話なんですね
成長する必要ないっていうことは
信じられない言葉なんですね
成長するべきです こんなのはもう証拠出す必要ない
当たり前のことで いくらでも証拠はありますね
生まれてきた赤ちゃんが成長しなくちゃあかんやとというのは当たり前であって
成長しなくていいよっていうことはありえないでしょう
赤ちゃんがいろいろいろいろことを学んで成長しなくてはいけないんですね
成長といえば幅広いでしょうし
肉体の成長に限りたわけじゃないんです
走ることできただけでいいわけじゃないんです
正しく走らなくちゃいけないんですね
抱かれて走っただけでも意味がないんです
何か目的があって走らなくちゃいけないんですね
だからそれだけでいいわけじゃないんです
その目的は良い目的か悪い目的かと
そこまで判断して 良い目的を目指して我々は人生を走らなくちゃいけないんですね
ただ 足が強くなっただけではものは済みません
だから足が強くなったら走れますけど
それだけではなく それに精神も加わってきて
知識も加わってきて 理解能力も加わってきて
人生を走るんです 成長に向かって
だからすごい世界がそこに現れてくるんです
だから生きることはそれやと理解すると
くだらない恐怖感とか
何食うかとか 誰を殺して食べるかとかね
そんなくだらない狭い動物的な次元をいたって簡単に破って
ものすごく美しい世界に突入することはできるんですね
そういうわけでお釈迦様が美しい言葉は長い長い間ね
魅了される言葉あったっても
それは人の成長につながらないならば
どうしますかと それはとっても危険なんです
成長するべきなんです
成長につながらないっていうことは
これなぜ危険かというと
全て無常でしょう 変化するでしょう
変化することは成長の線路に入れてない
ならば自動的にそこで壊れていくんですね
だから無常はストップできません
だから我々には道2つ成長するか破壊するかっていう2つしか成り立たないんです
俺はそんな変なことに興味ないんだとかね
精神世界とか興味ないんだとかね
だからといって私はもう堕落したくはないんだと
だからただ仕事をして
それなりに適当にご飯食べて
適当に遊んで生きてますよと
その人は成長もなく破壊もなくストップしてますかね
ないんでありえないんです
我は成長もなく破壊もなく
中立的な状態でいますよとは
これできないんです 物事は変化するんです
心も変化するんです それで必ず起きる変化の過程は成長という線路に入れておくんです
だから転がっていくんです
それは止まりません それだったら良い方向へ転がるようにする
そうしなきゃ 転がることによって壊れて壊れて壊れていくんですね
どこまででも それで言葉を聞いたら
その言葉が人の成長につながるものでなければいけません
発展につながるものでなければいけません
発展の中でも 仏教の専門はもう精神人格的な発展であり
心の発展であり 肉体の発展っていうのは
どんなアホにもできますからね
それはそんなにどうったことはないんです
肉体の発展というのは
頑張ったっても 肉体はくたびれて壊れていくものですね
だから無駄ですと それは最終的に無駄です
一時的に無駄わけじゃないんです
運動するのは無駄なわけじゃないんだけど
最終的には無駄ですね
毎日運動したんだからといって
老いることは避けられませんし
病は避けられませんし
死は避けられませんしね
だから一時的には役に立つんだけど
毎日運動する人も運動しない人も同じく老いて死にます
ですから 仏教はそれが体の健康ということはもうまずもう管轄外にしているんです
それはお釈迦様でなくても
誰にでも語れることはできます
語ることはできます ブッダにしかできないことをブッダが語るんです
心の成長 それからそれは無駄にはなりません
残るのはそれだけなんですね
そういうわけで 我々はこの社会でより豊かで
より発展するために使う大事な手段はパブリックスピーチなんです
パブリックスピーチがあるんだからこそ
我々は学校にも行きましたし
それなりに勉強もしましたしね
大学にも入りましたし
なんとか何とかもう卒業もしましたしね
だからそれは全てパブリックスピーチのおかげなんです
自分のパブリックスピーチ能力が上手だったら
自分が大学で書いたレポートは結構ウケます
教授たちの間で この人はいい人やとかね
頭がいいやとかね そういうわけで
我々はもう母親の教育も一応パブリックスピーチでしょ
母親が自分の子供だけに限ったことを教えている
教えているわけじゃないんです
母親は子供が公の人間という角度で見て組織しているんです
自分の好みに子供を合わせているわけじゃないんです
ですから 母親の言葉さえもパブリックスピーチなんです
それもパブリックスピーチであればあるほど
母親の言葉を子供はよく聞くんです
お母さんと子供だけの関係の話だったら
あんまり子供は  その聞きたくはないではなくて
そこら辺お母さんだからね
まあいいや もう許してくれという
もうなんとかごまかしちゃうんですね
しかし 母親が言うことはもう公のポイントやとわかると
子供はやっぱりこれはお母さん
これぐらいは黙っていなさいよということは言えなくなっちゃうんです
はい そういうわけで このパブリックスピーチと公で喋るという現象があるんだからこそ
我々には学ぶこともできて
成長することもできましたから
これはとっても大事に安心
しっかりと守らなくちゃいけないことで
もう世の中これはものすごく悪用しているんだから
そこはもう気をつけなくちゃいけない
これは一人一人の責任なんですね
ですから 人が勝手にしゃべる
しゃべりなさい あなたはと
美しい言葉で 美辞麗句で
どうぞぼや頑張ってくださいと
内容はあるかないかと俺が調べると
認めるかないか私は決めると
あなたの話を聞くか聞かないかということを私は決めると
いう責任は自分で持たなくちゃいけないんです
それで我々はやっぱり成長っていうのは断言的に欠かせないものであると
秒単位でも人間は成長しなくちゃいかないんだということで
人の話を聞かなくちゃいけない
それだったら大量の話を我々には聞かないでゴミ扱いすることはできるんです
困らなくてもいいんです
それでヤムスットアウパサンマティ
ウパサンパティっていうのは心の乱れがなくなって
怒り 嫉妬 欲 あらゆるあらゆる感情で心が乱れて
もう混乱しているんですね
荒波立ってるんですね
心がこの貪瞋痴の荒波が抑えて落ち着く
ならばそれこそ言葉ですと
それは一言葉でも十分だよと
はい ではパブリックスピーチの場合は
どんな決まりにするのかいと
で 一芸で言っているのは
パブリックスピーチの場合はね
たくさん美しい言葉を語るということではなくて
心が貪瞋痴から貪瞋痴の舵がね
いくらか沈めるならば
一言葉でも十分だと それに価値があるんだと
人類が語る言葉 言葉世界のは価値がないんだということです
で 世の中のパブリックスピーチ
ほとんど怒りをかき立てるでしょ
欲をかき立てるでしょ
自我をかき立てるでしょ
興奮させる目的でしょ
戦争しようではないかと
平和運動も戦いましょうということで終わるんです
はい それでポイントは覚えてください
心が静かになる この静かになるというのは
何もやりたくない状態になることではなくて
この汚い荒波がなくなる
おとなしくなる で 心の調教につながる単語が個でも良いと優れているんだと
では 百一の偈でも同じこと言ってますね
その場合は単語一個だけ変わってます
サハッサンピチェーガータそれだけ
ガータっていうのは偈ですね
歌ですね 詩 歌 ポエム なんでこれ入れたかというと
これはインドの文化ですね
パブリックスピーチは歌で言うんです
即興で優れますよ ものすごい上手な人々がいる
だから当然その人々は知識人たちなんです
ものすごく言語 言語を学んで
文法を学んで 歌の作り方をすごく学んで
今までの先生方の歌を全部暗記して分析して学んで
で知識を得ているんですね
一旦作品を作ったら 誰にでもそれを暗記することはできます
だから 一般的に喋る人よりもガータで喋るならばもう大変ですよ
その人はもう知識人に決まっている
もう先生で決まっている
もう だからインド文化では結構ガータで喋ることもあり
お釈迦様もガータで喋ったり
一般の言葉で喋ったり
両方使っていたんです
時々お釈迦様が説法するとガーター芸をて詩でダダダダと喋る場合もあったし
その時内容は結構大変です
しっかり締まった内容で
そのまま暗記しなくちゃいけなくなっちゃうんです
そこまで頭の中でプログラミングするんだから
相当の能力なんです 今ならちょっと紙に書いてみて
もう間違ったものをカットして
こんな贅沢はできません
全部頭でやらなくちゃいけないので
だからガーターで喋る場合はやっぱり影響力は強いんです
先入観は人間にありますから
先入観というよりは事実ですからね
即興でガーターでパブリックスピーチできるならば
歌でパブリックスピーチできるならば
まあ頭がいいに決まってるんだから
それでもお釈迦様がそんな全能芸を作って語っても
心が成長しないならば意味がない
だったら一偈で十分やと
心は安らぎを感じる 安穏を感じる
貪瞋痴の炎が消える 一偈
二行か二行にするか 四行にするかっていうのはあんまり変わりはないんですけど
大体まあ四節というんですか
四句 四句ですね まあ四句の一偈で十分やと
その場合 えかんがーたーぱだんと言うんだから
一句ですね おそらく ガータといえば四つの行でできちゃうんですね
四つの行は パダは四つですね
四行 四行で偈が成り立つんです
四句で このテキストを見るとガーターパダンですから
四行もいらん 一句でも十分やと
心が清らかになるならば
はい それでまた明確ですね
私たちはあなたの言葉を聞いて
私の心が清らかになるかならないかというだけの尺度で身を守る
守ってくださいと 別にもうあの人の話聞くのよ
この人の話聞くのよ そんなのはもうどうでもいいことで
我々は自由は自由です
自分の自由はそのまま保てます
しかし 自分が人の話を聞く時は
こいつの話を聞いたらここから成長するのかいと
するわけないで それだったら別なところに行く
相手が誰であっても 言うことはすごい立派で
立派なことを言うんですね
勉強になりますねという気分になったら学んでくださいと
それではいい人間になりますよということで
自分で免疫をつけるんですよ
これって大変冗談じゃないんです
だから私はジョロンと長い間喋ったんです
これはもう人間にはもう欠かせない一つの現象なんですよ
パブリックスピリットというのは
空気なしに生きていられないぐらい
我々にもこの公の話がなし
生きていられないんです
だから免疫は自分で作るんです
しょうがないでしょ 空気にウイルスが飛んでいるならば
私はどうします？空気に文句を言う
空気に対して訴える 自分がマスクを着けて身を守るしかないんです
お釈迦様はそれを教えているので
自分でちゃんとマスクをつけなさいと
空気を吸いなさいではないんです
はい  3番目 この場合は数が少なくなっているだけで Yo
che gatha satang bhase
誰かがgatha偈を百作って語る
百の偈っていうのはだいたい一つの講演ぐらいになります
だいたい一 二時間ぐらいの量なんです
しかしAnattapada samhita無益な言葉ばっかしで
成長には関係ないんです Ekan
dhamma padam seyoそれより一つ
そのダンマパダで真理を入っている一句でよろしいと
法句ですね 一つの法の句
法句が一個で十分だと
法というのは真理ということで
本当のこと 知らなくてはならないこと
ダンマパダ 真理の言葉ですね
だったら真理の言葉は一個でも十分でしょうと
ヤン・スットワ・ウパサムマティ
それ聞いたらあなたの心の無知がなくなって
心が安穏の状態に達すると
いうことで終わりになります
まあ 百一と百二のはあんまり差がないんですね
ただ 百一の場合は千の偈になっていて
百二は百の偈になっているだけで
おそらくはこの百二の偈で
このあるテーマに絞って偈で語ることを考えていたかもしれません
その場合は百偈で語るということは相当の大作品なんですね
しかし 一つのテーマに絞っているんです
あるテーマに絞って 百の偈で詩で歌っても
それは有益ではないならば
無益なものであるならば意味がないんだよと
それだったら法が真理入ってる一句で十分だと
で こういうスタイルでお釈迦様は一応語りましたから
例えばこの四句の一句で真理語ってる偈もありますよ
例えば皆様よく知っている
サッベーサンカーラアニッチャーとかね
諸行無常である あれは四句の一句なんですね
それで全部真理語ってます
出来上がっている一切の現象は無常であり
これ聞いただけで ものすごいとんでもない何か世界に我々は入り込みますよ
一切の現象という自分ですからね
無常であると 分かった途端
心のやるかす 愛やら自我やらエゴやらもう消えちゃいますよ
幸いに理解できないだけですけど
あの一句を理解するだけでも
びっくりして心がものすごく超越して
自我のない世界に突入するんです
だからヤダパンニャーイ・パッセティ
それは智慧で見られるならば
何だったっけ ニッサンギョーは
ニッビンダティ  アタ・ニッビンダティ・ドゥッケ
それから諦めますよと
この生きることに対しては
諦めがつくんだ いわゆる渇愛がなくなるんですね
このニッビンダティという単語も
見事に脳科学的にぴったし合ってるんだよと
あの本に書いてあります
この単語 言葉自体が 脳の立場から
医者として脳の発展という立場から見ると
そのためにはこのこれが必要だと
諦めちゃう この諦め 英語でイクアニミティと言うんですけど
負うこともないし逃げることもない
状態なんですね だから人生に対して何か負う
何か目的 それもなくなる
もう逃げたい逃げたい
それもない それが諦めなんです
どうってことないだろうという感じでいることですね
だからサッベーサンカーラ・アニッチャー
それだけは真理の言葉なんですね
それからちょっと説明で
四句で偈を完成しているだけ
それから皆様知っている
このナヒ・ヴェーレーナ・ヴェーラーニという偈はね
怒りは怒りで治めませんということは
日本訳で簡単なんですけど
パーリ語だったら二句で完成するんですね
ナヒヴェーレーナヴェーラーニサッマンティーダクダチャナン
クダチャナン いつだって言われる
永遠に ということでネバーということですね
ヴェーレーナヴェーラーニ
怒りを返すことで怒りがなくすということはあり得ません
それで二句で法が完成している
真理が完成しています
それで反対のことアヴェーレーナチサッマンティ
答え 怒らないことによって治めますよと
それで話が終わり あともう一個足らないんですね
四句にしなくちゃあかんだから
それでもう一個つなげるんです
エーサダンモーサナ そんなのはいつだって同じことだと
これは普遍的な真理だよと
法則だよということで
四句で偈を完了するんですが
真理は二行で終わっているんです
そこでまた四行目までいかないと完了しない偈もありますね
まあ今更いろいろそんな講義する目的はなかったんですから
思い出せませんだけど
例えば八十二偈 ヤターピラハドーガンビーロヴィッパサノーアナーウィロ
湖がね とてもとても深い湖がとても澄んだ水があるように
エーワンダンマーニ・スッタ
真理を聞いた人の心も澄みますよと
明らかになりますよと
この場合は四句も必要なんですね
意味を理解するために
意味はどれでも一個に入ってます
真理を聞きなさいっていう
聞くべきなのは真理だということはもう魂ですね
偈の それは一個に入ってますけど
主体としては四句も必要なんですね
ほとんどの偈の場合は大体二句で真理のポイントは完了しているんですね
そこでも私個人的な悩みなんですけど
それが全部覚えてほとんど覚えているんですけど
三行目と四行目忘れちゃうんです
あれで完了しているんだから
脳がはい終わりとそこでストップかけてるんです
私の場合は だから三行目何でしたっけ？とまた苦労して思い出さなくちゃいかんですね
それでも思い出せない場合もあります
これってお釈迦様の教え方だからそうなっているんですね
でしっかり理解するべきポイントはあるところをきちっと脳に留まるんです
完了するために入れている他の句はもう別になくたっていいんじゃないかっていうことで
脳はスペース取っちゃいます
それはなくても大丈夫です
これは必要ということで
はい まあそれはあの偈のあの
お釈迦様の教えの教え方なんですね
とにかくお釈迦様はガーターで偈で詩で説法します
普通説法もします 詩で説法する場合は
やっぱり聞いてる人々も知識人で知識人でなければ困ります
聞いてる人々もよく学んでいる
よく知識人でなければもう困りますし
喋ってる人も大変ですよ
ちゃんと文法通りに偈を作らなくちゃいけないんだからね
一つの一つの字でも伸ばしてはアカンし
短くなってもいけませんし
長短の組み合わせいろいろあるし
いろいろありますから
そこは決まりの中でやらなくちゃいけない
例えば自教なんか調べてみてください
初めから終わりまで あれどんなあれなんでしたっけ？あのチャンダスは
よくわからない スローガンかもしれない
スローガン  じゃないか
ちょっと長い  これスローガンではなくて
スローガンは短いんですから
特別そうな名前あるんです
うん まあ結構あれ歌うのは大変なんですけどね
あの字教はね 唱えるのは大変なんでけど
決まりあります しかし
あれ終わりまで完璧に変えることなく
同じ調子で書いてますね
短い句と長い句 短い句
長い句 短い句 長い句でつなげていくんです
はい そういうところに興味持っちゃうと意味どうなるのかっていうことはね
美しい偈を語ろうと思っちゃうと
なんか言語の角になっちゃうんですね
その角取りじゃないんです
だから仏教はそれは気をつけるんです
あくまでも意味が大事ですよと
意味というのは 人は人格的に成長することであって
だから この美しさに惹かれるなかれというなんですね
まあ能力があれば 意味のある言葉を美しい句で唱えても一向に構わない
その方がとてもよろしいんです
美しい句は唱えられますけど
さっぱり意味のアイディアがないならば黙っていろよと
お前うるさいだけやと
言葉は美しく語るんだけど
内容はないんだったら黙っていろよ
うるさいだけ 言葉は同じ
美しくなくても大事な内容を語るならば
それで十分よっていうことになるんです
はい 一応以上 今日はそこら辺で
はい  今日はどうもありがとうございました
人とするもですが 人の言うことを鵜呑みにしないと
それで自分で判断しなさいというお話でしたけども
それで自分で判断して
よければそれを肯定して
良くなければ否定するということでしたけども
例えばその人がまだ修行が未熟で
高い低いのことがわからない状態だとした場合に
その状態で否定してしまうっていうのはちょっとどうかと思ったんですが
お釈迦様はどういう風におっしゃってるんでしょう
それは現実的にはそういう問題がありますけど
やっぱりこの小さな子供の時から物事を調べてみると
私 調べてみたんだからね
やっぱり子供でも自分で納得しないとやらないんですよ
これはダメって言ったってやるんですよ
だからこれはこの脳のと心の一つの基本的な法則だと思いますね
実際ではいろいろトラブル
おっしゃったようにね
自分で何がわからない場合はね
困るでしょうっていうことはありえますけど
自分もまだわかってないくせに
もう否定しちゃうとね
これは困りますけど やっぱりそんなことはあっても
だから子供にしつけしてみると
こいつらは全然聞いてくれないんですね
言ってること正しいなのに
それで私はなるほど この子供たちは自分が納得したらやるんですよ
それで納得するように喋るんです
私なら いろいろ別な手段で喋るんです
そうすると 何のことなく言ったことをやるんです
この間もね まあ夜寝ないで
まあガチャガチャガチャガチャガチャふざけて遊んでいるんですね
朝早く起きて学校に行かなくちゃいけないんですよ
いい加減寝なさいと言っても寝ない
まあ子供はまあ興奮しているし
楽しいし だからもう遅くなっているんだっていうことは知らないしね
時計見せてもあまり実感がないんですね
で 私はまあまあ別に言う
まあ朝は誰も起こしません
一人一人が自分で起きて来てくださいと
はい どうぞと もし誰かが起こしたらこんなことやるぞと
子供何人か一緒に寝るんですね
誰が先に起きて隣の人を起こしたらこんなことやる
朝はもうみんな一人一人で起きなくちゃいけないんだと
はい終わり これで怖くなっちゃって
みんな寝ているんです
何のことなく これ自分でわかるんですね
やっぱり普通は 遅くまで遊んじゃうと
やっぱり俺は朝がすごく眠くてしょうがないやとかね
自分の経験あるんだからね
だからもうその都度その都度その同じフレーズはいつでも聞きませんだけど
その都度その都度相手が納得するようにと喋れないと相手が理解しないんですよ
だからそれが脳と心の構造
基本構造であるんですよ
それを理解してほしいんです
もう社会 状況としての問題じゃないんですね
数学は面白くないんだから私はやめましたという風なのは
それはまあ後の話なんです
基本的には 心は自分で納得してからやるんですね
だから宗教に仏教は反対なのは
その機能を取り消すんですね
信仰しなさいと なんで信仰しなさいっていうことはあまりにも世の中で強烈かというと
また同じ問題なんですね
子供に喋ってみると 言うことを聞いてくれない
くれないんですよ これで親が困るんですね
そこで信仰というこの恐ろしい
この強引な手段を入れちゃうと
子供には選択はできなくなっちゃうんですね
それで命令ですよ し 命令に無批判的に従うという
そういうこの成長の一つの成長に欠かせない一つの原因を取り除いているんですね
信仰が あれは仏教 とっても危険なことだと
人類にはそれ以上不幸なことはないんだというふうに知っているんです
だからイスラム教の世界の子供たちはみんなすごくおとなしいんです
ものすごくおとなしい
見たらものすごくいい子供たちですねと私も思っちゃうんですよ
もう学校終わってどう行く時でも
まあすごいかっこよくて
いい加減なことは何もなくて
行儀よく 日本ではないんで
自分の国ではね イスラムの教の子供も人々は結構いますからね
そこでもう学校終わるとイスラム教の学校の子供たちと普通の学校の子供たちは下校するのを見ると
こいつらもう猿の群れが
檻を破ったような感じで
イスラム教の学校から出ている子供たちはちゃんと並んでじーっと綺麗に出るんです
だから学校終わる時は警察が大変
各学校の前に警察官が行くんですよ
子供たちを守ってあげなくちゃいかんから
行ってもみんなそれぞれ車に乗って
バスに乗って出ている間にもう車管理したりとかね
それ終わったら警察官たちはまた戻ります
だから考えることでも
毎日学校下校する時間になってくると
警察が来て交通整理するっていうことはどういうことかと
日本でもないですよ そんな現象は
別に子供たちは暴動を起こしてるわけでも何でもないんですよ
もう体も弱いし 大したことないんだけど
やっぱりあの厳しい言葉で管理されてないんです
仏教だからほとんど だから自分で判断する能力は取り除いてないんです
でも子供たちだから 何を判断すればいいかわからないでしょう
だからハチャメチャなんです
それで隣の学校はイスラム教だったら何のこともなく警官もいりませんし
ちゃんと あちらはもう信仰でカコンと釘を打って
自分で判断する能力を取り除いているんです
はい そういうことも現実的な問題もあるんですけども
修行で例えば高い次元の世界のこととかですね
あるいは業のこととか
そういう自分で証明しきれないことをパブリック的に言うっていうのは
言われた場合に それを信じるか信じないか
自分では体験できないし証明できないから信じませんという態度になっちゃうと
ちょっともうそこでストップしちゃってもったいない
仏教の場合はもうそう言葉言わないんですね
私に私にできません だから信じませんっていうのは
それ自体バカバカらしいでしょ
言ったらそれですぐ負けますよ
お前全て知ってると思ってますか？知らないこといくらでも世の中あるだろうと
ちょうどそういうふうにおっしゃるのいいですけど
我々ちょっとそこまで相手に対して言い切れないところがありますので
だから丁寧に言えば同じこと丁寧に
ただ表現のあれだけですけどね
はい どうもありがとうございました
あともう一つ ちょっと関係ないんですけども
仏教には自然法則として五つのものがあると
ニヤーマっていうですね
ウトゥ・ニヤーマとヴィーリヤ・ニヤーマとチッタ・ニヤーマとカンマ・ニヤーマ
ダンマ・ニヤーマ この最後のダンマ・ニヤーマっていうのはどういうもの？どういうふうに理解したらよろしいでしょうか
うーん だからニヤーマは 四つか五つかっていうのはね
四つで十分やと思いますけどね
カンマ チッタ ヴィーリヤ
ウトゥとダンマ・ニヤーマ
あのね カンマ チッタ ヴィーリヤ
ウトゥって全部この一応存在に対してこの物質ですね
結局は 心でも物質精密に働くし
で カンマ 業は心のことなんで
やっぱり物質なしにはね
それは働かないでしょ
チッタ 心っていうのはね
肉体がないとあるんですかね
だからそれは普通世界に我々の調べることはできる範囲で
しかし 真理 法則はそれだけに限っている
それだけということは言えないんですね
ですから 生きることは苦であるということはダンマ・ニヤーマなんですね
チッタ・ニヤーマでもないし
カンマ・ニヤーマではないんですね
ヴィーリヤ・ニヤーマではないしね
ウトゥでもないんですね
それ何がなくても生きることは苦で成り立っているというね
で 無常であるということはね
一切現象は無常であるということはダンマ・ニヤーマなんです
それで無我 これもダンマ・ニヤーマなんです
ヴィーリヤ・ニヤーマじゃないんです
チッタ・ニヤーマでもないんです
そういうわけで この世の中の生命を調べて
お釈迦様が発見した真理は全てダンマ・ニヤーマに入るんです
わかりました ありがとうございました
えっと 他に質問ある方
いや あの 今日のですね
お話に直接関係ない質問で恐縮なんですけども
先週ですね 私の義父が亡くなりまして
それで少しまだ心が動揺したりしておりまして
以前長老から亡くなった方のことはもうどうしようもないので放っておいた方がいいというようなことを言われたことを思い出したりもしているんですけれども
仏教国でですね 例えば親が亡くなった時に
子供とか遺族の方が亡くなった方のために何か唱えるお経みたいなものがあるのであればですね
教えていただきたいなと
それを唱えることで少し自分の心がですね
落ち着くような気もしておりますので
その点ちょっとお願いしたいと思います
仏教の世界ではね 親が亡くなったら回向しますからね
法要やらいろいろことをやってね
回向して より幸福でありますようにと
一生懸命供養しますよ
それは亡くなられた方々に対してのやってあげる
あげられるもの それだけ
もう一つは 自分の心はどう治めるのかという
自分だけのわがままな問題もあります
親が亡くなって悲しくてたまらないというのはあなたのわがままですからね
だから私たちのわがままで悲しくなっちゃいますね
だからそれはなくす方法はまた別であってね
親が亡くなりました それはもう法則だからしょうがないと
しかし 親はもう散々親に迷惑をかけてきてきましたから
親にも何か何とか恩返ししてあげたいと思っちゃうと
色々法要があるんですね
親に供養する法要はあります
それは親のためにやっていますし
供養はやってあげても
やっぱり自分がそれでも悲しいと
というところははっきり言えば自分のわがままなんですね
人が死んで悲しくてたまらないということは
わがままもいいところだけの話なんですね
それはどうしましょうかということでね
その場合は死に対しているお経あるでしょう
何？ 選挙  選挙を唱えてみたりとかね
で 慈経を唱えてみたりとかね
すればよろしいと思いますね
北島大観さんという方が編集されたダンマパダを読んでるんですが
今日の百番百一番の偈の後にエピソードがついているんですけども
百番のエピソードを読みますと
引退した斬り切り役人が引退した斬り切り役人が説法を聞いて
何らかの悟りの境地になった
だけれど その直後に牛の角に突かれて死んでしまったというエピソードがついているっておりまして
で 百一の方のですね 偈のエピソードを見ますと
バーヒヤという行者がですね
お釈迦様の説法を聞いて直ちにこれはもう最終的な悟りになったけれども
その直後にですね やはりその牛の角に突かれて死んでしまったと
以前 長老の解説でこのにも載ってますけども
偈の六十六番というのがありまして
それのエピソードは ハンセン病の患者がですね
やはり説法を聞いて最初の段階の境地に達したけれども
その後牛に突かれて死んでしまったというのがあるんですけども
その悟ったっていうか
説法を聞いて何らかの悟りの境地に達した
それが最終段階だろうか
最初の段階だろうか 関係なくですね
そういう場合は このエピソードが意味するのは
その後はもう目的が達成されたんだから
真理のお釈迦様の真理の一端が分かったんだから死んでもいいというような意味なんでしょうか
ちょっと言い過ぎかもしれないですけど
何か共通してその直後に牛の角に突かれて死んでもいいのか何か意味があるのかと思うんですけど
私は見事に牛に轢かれね
みんな大事な方々はね
何でしょうかと 私はあんまりそういうエピソードを使わないのはそういうわけでもあります
このいくつかのエピソードはあったと思いますよ
とにかくバーヒヤ・ダールチーリヤという阿羅漢のエピソードは私も使います
なぜかというと それはエピソードではなくて
経典にちゃんとその出来事はしっかりと記録していますから
バーヒヤ・ダールチーリヤという阿羅漢は出家する前にも牛に轢かれて亡くなられたということは事実だったと思います
他至るところであれもこれもというのはね
どうかなとわからないし
まあ現代インドの状況を見ると
あまり珍しくもない どういたっても牛ばっかりだからね
でも牛っていうのは 今インドの牛はもう猫よりすごく優しいんですよ
理由はもう長い間インド人は牛肉食べてないでしょ
だから殺してないんですね
だから牛の寿命は短いし
だから牛の遺伝に もう遺伝
インドの牛たちっていうのは
人間っていうのはもう敵でも何でもない
もう仲間ということになってるんですね
だからでっかい見る限り怖そうな牛でも
もうどうやって押したらもうちょっと自分その気になるならば寄せてくれるし
俺が動けませんよと思ったら動かないようにもするし
もう全然敵がないんですね
だから全く安全ですよ
牛の間で子供がいたとしてもね
踏まれて死ぬって それはない
当時は牛はよく食べられましたから
バラモン人に だから牛も身を守らなくちゃいけないことで
放し飼いの牛が凶暴になるということもあり得るしね
だからでもよくわからない
そんなのは私もなんでそうなるのかと
仏教の教理学的に言えば
阿羅漢に達したら まあ 1分でも別に生き延びる意味がないんです
別に だからまあ自然に肉体の機能止まるまで一応いるんですけど
これは事故で壊れてしまったら
これまたありがたいということになるんですね
死はあんまり全然気にしないんだからね
で 輪廻から見ても 死はまるっきり気にするものじゃないしね
もう死んでは生まれるは死んでは生まれるは
今も死んで生まれて死んで生まれて生き続けてるだけで
生きるということは 生と死でできているんだから
びっくりすることじゃないんですね
しかし 一般人がこの人生だけあまりにも気を付けるんだから
もうとにかくもう何をしてでも生きてみるぞという人にとっては
死は大変なものなんですね
あれはただの幻覚なんですね
人間が持っているこの死に対する恐怖と
死んではいかんということもね
ただの幻覚に過ぎないんですね
普通はいつでも死があって生きているんですね
今も我々はもう死んで死んで死んで次次のものを作っているんだから
常に輪廻なんですね それってあんまり意味がないんだから
阿羅漢に達したらOK
もうゴールですね だから残り短いところは続けるかないか
ということの話ですね
一応阿羅漢に至っては自殺したいということは意味は成り立たない
何かやりたいためには煩悩が必要ですからね
煩悩がないんだだから自殺したいともないし
生きていたいともないんですね
だから ただ物質はつなげている間は
まあそれで生きていて
その間でいっぱい説法して
自然に涅槃に入るんですね
まあ一つはそういうエピソードで
突然亡くなったということは
仏教は大げさにしてないだけの話なんです
全然大げさにしない 例えば洪水で村一つなくなったんだからといってね
ああ 大変だ なんだこれとかね
どんな神が怒っただろうとか
全然仏教は気にしない
そんなことは 日本に起きた大震災に至っても
なんだこれとか それは誠に悲しいことであると
人々の苦しみは限りないものであると理解するんであって
残された人々には何か助けてあげることがあればやりましょうよと
だからってそれは答えではありませんと
助けてあげたっても苦しみは苦しみであると
潰れた家に家の代わりに新しい家を作ってあげたっても
苦しみは苦しみであると
そういうわけで 復興っていうのは
街を新しく作ることでは復興になりませんよと
心の苦しみ 悩みをなくすことこそが復興であると
それだったら津波にやらなくても我々も同じ運命でいるんですからという立場ですね
仏教は だからあまり大げさにしないんですね
そういうことは 当時 お釈迦様の時代では
そういう理不尽的な死にというのはものすごいありましたから
もうね とんでもない王の連中もいましたし
いろんなもう暴動を起こしたりするグループもいましたし
王の管理下ではなくて
森の中で生活しているこの泥棒グループもいましたし
泥棒と言ったって あれは泥棒じゃなくて泥棒コミュニティなんですよ
だから怖いのはもう並みじゃないんです
だから 一つの国からもう一つの国に行くのはもう大変なんですよ
この境界線はなかったんだけど
その国と国の間では もう無人
誰も管理していない森とか砂漠とか
なんとかあるんですね
そこは泥棒たちが自分の泥棒の国を作って生活している
そこで税金払って盗賊ではなくて
戦災産奪うんです だからもう理不尽的な死っていうのはね
ものすごくあったんですね
この まあ一応この一般人の間ではダンマパダといえばエピソード
物語を聞くことやと勘違いしているんです
昔からミャンマーも同じことで
だからエピソード言っちゃえば日本人も驚くだろうと思ってそれを書いているんです
で 私は驚く方々はどうぞその本を読んで驚いてくださいと
もうお釈迦様がおっしゃった意味は
私は説明しますということで
私の解説のやり方はミャンマーでもスリランカでもやらないんです
それは構わないんだけど
お坊さんたちも結局ダンマパダの意味を忘れているんです
エピソード言っちゃえばいいと思っているんです
例えば 今日私は説明したこのパブリックスピリチュアルという現象について
お釈迦様はすごいことをおっしゃっているのに
パブリックスピリチュアルの我々の人生にいかに欠かせないことであるかということをね
これがものすごい大事なポイントでしょ
我々ずっと晒されてますから
人々の話に だったら自分がいかに身を守りつつ成長しなくちゃいけないというすごい宿題が抱えているのに
そういうところをあまりスリランカで喋ったっても人気ないんです
だから私の話も人気ないんです
私は国へ帰ったら説法しないんです
説法しない 別なやり方でやるんです
かなり効くんです この前ではっきり言ったんです
あんた方はね なんでこんなにも世界的に頭が悪いかというと
朝から晩まで説法を聞いているんだから
世界一頭が悪いの  [笑い]信者さんもなんか笑って何言ってるかよくわからないんだけど
それからやってることをはちゃめちゃこれやってるでしょ？こういうこともやってるでしょ？こういうこともやってるでしょ
こんなの何やと はっきり言うともうもう黙ってる
今度の法要の時のお坊さんたちに説法だけはしないでくれとはっきり言ったんです
これまた説法始めて 私はもうやれやれ
何やってるのかと 私一応後ろにいるんだけどね
なぜかと ものすごいたくさんの人々がものすごい来たんです
今回はもう他のお寺の信者さん
自分は珍しく来て だから私は一言葉でみんな管理しているんです
はい 座ってくださいと言ったら
みんなさっさと座る まあこれで終わりですから
まあ解散って言ったら
みんな何のことなく解散する
一言二言葉で これであの
もともと仏教は信仰であれ
抑えてないんだから みんなもう野生の猿なんですよ
思ったことをやるんだから
ものすごい管理難しいんですよ
仏教の世界では 自分で判断する世界だから
これでお坊さんたちが説法しちゃって
もう大変になっちゃったんだ
最後のもう最後はもうもう考えたんだよ
私が全てやりますかと思ったら
私が全てやっちゃうと信者さんはものすごく喜ぶのは確かでしょうし
お坊さんたちはむちゃくちゃびっくりするだろうと
しかし えらいお坊さんたちが来て
何も自分でやるパートがなくなっちゃうと
なんか立場がないんですね
だからお坊さんたちに任せますと言って
まあすごい短く ぶりに短くで任せましたけど
最後の説法はね 本山のお坊さんに頼んだんですね
本山のお坊さんよりも年上の長老たちが並んでいたんです
それで本山のお坊さん
えっ 私がやるんですか？と
私は他の誰か長老が説法すると思ってましたよと言ったら
私は何のことだかマイクロフォンを授けてましたけど
いいまあ説法できるお坊さんが一人もいませんだから
大丈夫です と言っても
だからそういう風に冗談で言っちゃうと
自分の説法は短くした方がいいんだ
いい いいんじゃないかなということは
まあ言っているんですけどね
まあまあ 適当に何とか言ったらいいやという話でしょう
本当はすごく偉いお坊さんたちがいたんで
お坊さんたちは聞こえましたから
みんな笑ってね もう話はもう説法できる人一人もいませんから
じゃああんたやってくださいと
だからみんなまあなんとか楽しく早く終わるだろうと
これは終わらないんですね
伸びますね だからまあとにかくまあ
こういう伝統的な決まった説法をすることが決まりやと思ってるんだから
ダンマパダになってくると
なんだらかんだらのエピソードを言わなきゃダメなんです
もしエピソード言わないで
お経 芸の説明だけすると
あれ このお坊さんが何か覚えてないみたい
ということになるんです
大恥なんです だから私は毎回
かじかけられます あえて言わないんです
エピソードは だからこのそれから私の問題はこのエピソードと芸が合わないんですね
全部すべての芸にエピソードがあるんだけど
合うものもあるし 合わないものもあるし
だから放っておいた方がいいやと決めたんです
まあそんなにまあ そんなところなんですね
他に質問ある方いらっしゃいますか
すいません 今日の話の中で脳の話が出たので
ちょっとそれでお聞きしたいのですが
現代の学者の人たちは
いわゆる唯物論ならぬ唯一脳論というんですか
脳がすべてであるとか
人間の行動とか心とかっていうのは
脳によってすべて行われていることだっていいますが
仏教的に言うとそれは正しいっていう風に言ってしまってもいいんでしょうか
いや これは全く間違ってない
それで他に関連してもう一つ
もう 2つ聞きたいんですけども
いわゆる脳死問題というのが一時期話題になったことがありますが
その脳死っていうのも
それも脳による死を死であるというふうに認めちゃってもいいのかどうかっていうのと
あとちょっとそれとまたあれなんですけど
今コンピューターとかがそうやって発達してきて
将来的に人工知能というのができる可能性もあると思うんですが
その場合にその人工知能ができた時に
それは生命として認めてしまってもいいのかどうか
その 3点についてすいませんが
ちょっとお聞きしたいです
3点の 1個しか意味がないんですね
まああの脳は心ではありませんね
まあだからこの唯脳論
脳はすべてだっていうことはあまりみんな思ってないんですね
心は別に働きますよということはちゃんと知っている人の人は今参考に出した本の場合でも
あれも脳の科学者たちですけど
心という別なフェノメノンというか現象は認めるんですね
で だからこの脳はこの機械で
で ただの機械でね また別に心は働くんだっていうことはね
言ってはいるんです まだまだ科学的に最終的に結論は出てないんですからね
科学はまだまだ発展途上でね
もう発展完了している仏教と比較するとちょっと困ります
で まあそういうことで
まあ唯脳論は仏教は認めないというところで覚えておいてください
どちらが正しいかはわからない
まあそれから研究すればよろしいし
脳死の場合は これはもう世間の問題で
仏教では答えられるものではありません
仏教の定義は まあ自力で生きていられない場合は自然に死にますね
生きることは自力でやるもんなんです
この自力でやることはっていうのは自然法則なんですね
それは人間がいじってるだけの話なんです
あのカタツムリという動物がいるんですね
あいつはすっごいゆっくりな動くのは
これは見ていられないんだから
カタツムリを何か台につけて
台が早く動くようにしてあげたら
だからカタツムリは自分の筋肉を動かすと
台の歯車がすらっと動いてできますよ
こんなことやっていいんですかね
だからあるカタツムリはこちらの葉っぱ食べていて
ちょっと別なところの葉っぱ食べたいなと筋肉動かしたところで
ずーっと行っちゃうと
いて別なところで で これって今の技術ではいたって簡単にできます
いたって簡単にできます
これでカタツムリが早くなったんだから
これからカタツムリの人生どうしようかとか悩んだり
それで生命っていうのは自力で生きるんです
で 自力で生きていられなくなった瞬間に死にます
しかし 人間の医学では
肺はちょっと呼吸できなくなっちゃうと
機械入れてでも呼吸させてあげます
心臓が故障しちゃっちゃうと
別な心臓を入れてでも生き延ばしたりはします
これはいいか悪いかよくわかりませんだけど
まあそういうふうに人間の間で技術は発達しているんです
それで脳が死んでもまた機械で生きているとかね
あるいは体が死んじゃっても
脳がビシビシ動いているとか
いろいろあったりはしますね
だから答えは脳死は人の死というふうにも決めることはできませんし
体が機能低下したんだからといって人が死んだということも定義できません
で 自力で生き続けることができなかった瞬間で
すべての機能は停止するんです
それが本当の死なんです
おそらく脳が壊れちゃったらね
何も機械入れないで置いておけば
もうすぐ死ぬでしょう
脳が壊れたら呼吸もできませんだからね
だから現実的に計算すると
脳が死んだということは死んだということなんですね
復活は不可能ですね そういう理論で脳死は死になるんですね
しかし それは理論的な答えで
仏教の答えというふうにもするのもちょっと面倒くさいんです
それで終わりですか？質問が
ミスでしたっけね  もう一つ
いわゆる  人工知能 人工知能は生命ではありません
これ人工知能ですからね
それは大きな問題ではありません
人工知能が発達したっても
それはもうあと 300年ぐらいかかるかもしれませんよ
もうそんなもうできることじゃないんです
あれは計算ですからね
だから美学的感覚的な知能っていうのは生命特有なんです
例えば人工知能でこの花は美しいと
この花はもうちょっとダメだというふうに判断できません
人間にはできますね それで私が美しい花という花に
他の人はこれはもうダメですよという可能性もあります
とにかくこの美学ですからね
感覚好き嫌いというところは
人工知能では成り立ちません
で 美味しいと判断する機械は作れますよ
それで決まってる味があって
データ取って美味しい美味しくないとかね
もうデータ出せますけど
我々は本当に同じデータのものでも
美味しいと判断したものでも
ある時食べて やっぱり美味しいね
やっぱりまずいねと言っちゃうんですよ
勝手に その都度 その都度
その能力は機械には成り立ちません
あれは命に成り立つ能力なんです
このわがまま好き勝手っていうところは
わがまま好き勝手いい加減で理屈に入りませんという能力は命の能力なんです
ですから 人工知能は当然これからも出来上がると思いますけど
えー結構ひどい目に遭うと思いますけどね
それで 声明にはなりません
はい  わかりました ありがとうございます
それでは以上でよろしいでしょうか
他の方質問なければ皆さんで回向の文をお唱えして終了したいと思います
では皆さんが唱えてください
回向の文 仏法僧の三宝に礼拝帰依し
戒を守り 慈悲の瞑想とヴィパッサナー修行によって積まれたこの功徳を
神々 先祖 祖父母 両親 親族
恩師をはじめとし 一切の生きとし生けるものに回向いたします
この功徳によって すべての生きとし生けるものが幸福に暮らせますように
そして解脱を得ますように
Sabbe titayo vivajjantu Sabba
rogo vinassatu Mā
te pāṭhavantarāyo sukhee dīghāyuko bhava Bhāvodu
sabba maṅgalaṃ rakkantu sabba devatā Sabba
buddhānubhāvena sabba dhammanubhāvena sabba saṅghanubhāven
a sadā sotthi bhavantu
te abhivādena sīlissā niccaṃ vadāpacāyino catvāro
dhamma vaḍḍhanti āyu vaṇṇo
sukhaṃ balaṃ
はい ありがとうございました